Radiohead because I'm great so today's
topic pretense is really interesting
theory on music and why it's changed so
much over the years in certain genres
why certain genres have completely faded
like rock music I told you this I love
to be clear on we say funk music I'm
talking about stuff like Sly and the
Family Stone I'm talking stuff like
Funkadelic who's a guy will obviously
Earth Wind & Fire's a pretty good
example but a little bit different
George Benson is a good one Bobby Cole
yeah yeah but one thing I've noticed is
that funk music over the last 15 years
there's new artists who come up but they
don't do it properly
he doesn't grip people like what funk
you stick to the music didn't change if
the drug that did I think there's a
correlation with the drugs they were
doing and how the music came out okay
they were a lot of psychedelics back in
the days you know Jimi Hendrix all of
that the way the guitar was played it's
not the same I believe they were playing
and doing songs and they were seeing
things with the drugs that he were using
and in the drugs change sort of style
change I mean the beginning of that is
very psychedelic not just you know that
coke coke it's other things other drug
that makes you see things you know I
mean what did they were taking just
changed you take the hip hop back then
it was very straight forward lay there
were a lot of weed but it's interesting
because I had a lot of Jamaican
references at the time yeah because it
was a lot of Jamaicans back then it
changed it was not just sweet at first
it was other things and other things and
and now it's like all lean and
synthetics things that makes you just
melt down that's why the beat went from
onyx slam
the B goes which is much mellow and the
pattern that they used to talk they
repeat a lot of stuff because that's
what it makes you do yeah essentially so
I think that's what happened you don't
even dancing reflects that it used to be
high-energy jumping around whereas now
with computer it's yes one thing you
know right so it's a different yeah
that's the dance in the 90s that was
never dance that's not a running man
running man had to be energetic was just
everything changed back then as well you
know there was dance music there was
house music it was a lot of speed and
other things that makes you high now
it's really different look at Ricky the
reggae we were on what one are they on
now same thing did the Ricky changed no
the dancehall did because the dance
halls were following the trends of the
hip-hop and the dancehall did but this
Rick is still on the same thing and the
mood hasn't changed that much from the
70s to now the rock steady and all of
that it didn't really do do do do do do
- they're reusing the same beat as back
then look at new artists are coming out
they're young young but they're still on
the same kind of flow the beats are kind
of the same maybe there's more of an
influence from hip hop yes but the flow
still stays the same so that's so
interesting a lot of people don't
recognize this but most of the artists
that used to be prominent from the 70s
to the late 2000s like they were all on
something they were all taking
substances in their creative process
most of them admit it in their music or
in their biographies afterwards there's
pretty much no artist you can name that
kept that clean the whole time yeah and
it's funny because the old-school
hip-hop I was talking to you about about
that before and I hope the old-school
hip-hop heads are complaining about the
new school hip-hop heads because oh yeah
they're doing that mumbled rap but back
then they were talking about selling
crack where all the mumble rappers are
the products of the people that were
selling crack - do you think those two
are necessarily related though because
I'm not gonna say it's no no I'm nothing
I'm not saying it's exactly that I'm
saying it's funny that I also raised
something else is like people nowadays
from what I've come to understand don't
study music no they don't that was super
interesting to me he's like the stuff
of actual like how to make music that
breakdown that's just out the window
actually back then there was only one
person that was really bad at what he
was doing it was a Ringo from the
Beatles you look horrible drummer who's
the old guy right now the black guy who
exposed him Quincy Jones because he said
he worked with the beat instead the
drummer that was just terrible yeah so
they had to replace them basically
nowadays a lot of people don't study use
it for me that study of music is so
important you can be talented and that's
great but if you don't have a
fundamental understanding of how things
work not only will you not last but your
work will not last there's like NBA
players who don't have their
fundamentals that yeah you can be as
talented as you want it'll give you
three four year support yeah but
longevity you have to understand the
game itself in order to be able to let
us win to maximize your ability to win
yeah and so there's always that
separation even like that was common let
people don't have a fundamental
understanding and so they can put out
some good content for a short period but
if you want to talk about having a body
of words not making words that is
timeless and constant gotta understand
absolutely Eddie Murphy yeah like I just
saw I saw I saw just just uh Eddie
Murphy yeah SNL it's impossible to leave
that long not disease not do acting I
mean I can't come back and be that good
yeah it's almost impossible yeah he
understands it some people like D'Angelo
right he took his hiatus for like 14
years and came back with an album and
you know guys when they have a huge
success how can he come back 15 years
later it's due to but in this man's case
that album is not only great but it gets
better with time cuz you know and he
understands his own evolution and stuff
like that so for me I just like okay
artists today don't have that
understanding of music it's like one to
two layers yeah I meant the music today
has only one to two layers of yeah good
it is but it's deeper than that music
that always quite simple and resample
and resampled you know there's layers to
that what's funny because you could play
an old song from the 60s and 70s and you
feel like you put four songs and ones
yeah there's songs that's been sampled
like just a different part fragmented
and fragmented so much I mean that's all
that Kanye does what what's her name um
ninis
I don't know how many tracks that Kanye
took from me the same strategy just shot
one track yeah chop another big once
right it's like yeah he's using
everything and to be clear we're not one
of those old people who hates music I
love a lot of people what they're doing
right now big big thing I recognize the
difference between the time I didn't
grow up in that time that's like my
parents generation for it I recognize
how their music is just there was a
quality to it that is timeless to me
know that is like inherently I cannot be
denied and nowadays I don't know if we
have that same quality because I'm not
nostalgic about other categories for
example anime I think it's the best
place that's ever been
some people be like no before I'm like
no today right now they're making the
best stuff ever I feel that way about a
lot industries and so I'm not one of
those people who's stuck in the past all
the time back then it was based on
knowledge now it's based on trends yeah
because they need to say yeah and you
know this is not one of them is that's
gonna sell but no one
[Music]
but are you always coming in it's still
hitting me and still giving response 101
Oh who's gonna start a song like this
today is it's very even that note up and
down my faces they're not trying to make
it hit mom if it's that note it's that
note let me play that note I could play
that know the whole song I'm gonna play
three notes at some point my soul is
telling me not even to be on beat I'm
just gonna feel it though so that's why
we're not here music today I'm like it's
good like I can tell the terms of a
house like secrets it's well done but I
don't know if it reached his level where
it hits home for me
yeah I'm saying cuz I hear this stuff
and I'm just like what's happening like
I knew I was gonna play this for you I
listened to it earlier and I played it
again and it still hit home and there's
just certain works of art that do that
every time home one yeah and I guess
maybe the substances that they were
taking at that time just enable them to
just focus on that are you doing that
you're seeing things of course good to
know because I think I'm gonna just get
back on the mush but yeah this is just
an interesting theory I really liked
what you had to say about it and it
gives me a lot of stuff to think about
last thing that I'm right though yes the
theory it makes a whole lot of sense yes
yeah yeah it's also possible that it's
just one of the many pieces listen you
listen to the track and it sounds like
what they took yeah if I listened to
Kurt Cobain I listened
my friends and my I know what you took
bro yeah Radiohead because I'm okay
you're bringing out the Hennessy I don't
want no Han to see bring the Jack Daniel
all right Sweet Home Alabama you know
what he took yeah you know a little bit
of this and some hard liquor that's what
it was it sounds like you know I
definitely agree I'm pretty sure I'm
right on the money with this one but
anyways we want to hear what your
theories are why do you think music has
changed so much over the couple of years
obviously the industry's changed in
terms of the independence and how people
make money and all that stuff but we
want to know in terms of the quality of
the music the timelessness of it all why
do you think it's changed so much
[Music]